♪ ♪
>> Jessica: WELCOME BACK, IT'S
TIME FOR "THE FASTEST" FIRST UP,
THIS GUY COULD BE THE WORST
FUGITIVE EVER, AND HAVING AN
AUSTRALIAN MAN ON THE LAMP OR
TWO WEEKS DESPITE THE MASSIVE
TATTOO ON HIS FACE THAT SAYS THE
WORD FEAST.
AFTER POLICE PUT OUT THE
BUCKSHOT, CHANGING THE FACEBOOK
PROFILE PICTURE TO THIS.
REALLY, WHO DO WE HAVE, SOME
JOKE ABOUT IF YOU HAVE A FACE
TATTOO?
>> Jesse: IT'S ONE FELONY PER
FACE TATTOO.
>> Greg: DID THEY HAVE TO FIND
FIVE OTHER GUYS WITH FULL POLICE
TATTOOS?
WE DID FIND THE NEXT CONTESTANT
FOR "THE BACHELOR."
>> Jessica: DANA PITTARD
>> Dana: I AM REALLY SAD FOR
THE MOM OF THIS GUIDE, BECAUSE
THAT WAS A CHILD THAT I ASSUME
WAS LOVED BY HIS MOTHER AND
TURNED OUT THIS WAY.
AND RUINED HIS FACE, BUT I GUESS
HE IS --
'S BEFORE HIS LAST NAME IS
BEAST, HE LOVES HIS MOTHER.
>> Dana: AT LEAST HE HAS COVID
CONSCIOUS WITH THE MASK OVER HIS
FACE.
>> Jesse: I SALUTE THE FACT
THAT HE WAS ON THE LAMP OR TWO
WEEKS WITH THE FACE TATTOO LIKE
THAT.
IT'S PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT'S
EXACTLY RIGHT, HOW HE GETS AWAY
WITH TWO WEEKS, ON HIS KNUCKLES
THAT SAYS "GAME OVER" I DON'T
KNOW IF HIS MOTHER LOVES HIM,
BECAUSE THIS IS A WARRANT FOR
DOMESTIC -- DOMESTIC DISPUTE.
>> Dana: MAY BE HE HE WAS NOT
LOVED.
AT THE BEGINNING.
>> Jessica: AT THE BEGINNING
FIRST OR COME UP NEXT,
"STAR TREK" IS ABOUT TO GET
REAL.
♪ ♪
>> ENERGIZING.
>> Jessica: FACEBOOK FOUNDER
MARK ZUCKERBERG RELEASED WE ARE
A FEW SHORT YEARS AWAY FROM
HAVING HOLOGRAM CONVERSATIONS
WITH ONE ANOTHER, AND YOU COULD
BEAM IN A LIVE IMAGE OF YOURSELF
TO A MEETING OR EVEN RIGHT HERE
AT THE TABLE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: WHEN BRIAN KILMEADE
IS ON I WILL DEFINITELY DO THE
HOLOGRAM.
>> Jesse: I SAW A WOMAN AT THE
AIRPORT AND SHE WAS JUST SITTING
THERE LIKE THIS AND I THOUGHT
SHE WAS A REAL WOMAN.
>> Jessica: YOU SAW HOLOGRAM
AT THE AIRPORT.
>> Jesse: ALL HOLOGRAM WOMAN
AT THE AIRPORT SAYING NICE
THINGS.
IT IS TO BE ON LET'S SAY THAT
THERE IS A HOLOGRAM, DOES GREG
SPEAK THROUGH THE HOLOGRAM?
>> Greg: YES.
>> Jesse: HE HAS AT HOME ALL
THE TIME.
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT I DON'T
HAVE TO GET MY HAIR DONE ALL THE
TIME.
>> Jesse: YOU STILL HAVE TO
LOOK GOOD.
>> Greg: BUT IF YOU GO TO
JAIL, CAN YOUR HOLOGRAM GO TO
JAIL FOR YOU?
IF YOU GET A COLONOSCOPY?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: NO.
>> Greg: THE DENTIST.
>> Judge Jeanine: HOW ABOUT IF
YOU'RE HOLOGRAM GETS MARRIED,
YOU CAN SAY IT'S NOT ME.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHAT
MARK ZUCKERBERG DID.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jessica: I FEEL LIKE IT WAS
"THE FASTEST" A YEAR AGO THERE
WAS A BRIDESMAID THAT COULD NOT
TRAVEL TO THE WEDDING BECAUSE OF
COVID AND SHE HOLOGRAM TO.
>> Greg: I THINK YOU JUMP TO
THAT, JESSICA.
>> Jessica: THAT SOUNDS COOL.
DANA, YOU CAN HOLOGRAM PERCY.
>> Dana: IF HE COULD BE HERE,
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
I DON'T KNOW, I'M OLD FASHION
AND I DON'T LIKE IT.
I DON'T EVEN LIKE "STAR TREK"
WHEN IT WAS ON WHEN I WAS A KID.
>> Greg: I LOVE THAT SOUND.
>> Dana: I KNOW I WILL GET
HATE MAIL FOR IT, BUT I CANNOT
GET INTO IT.
>> Greg: TOO CEREBRAL.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: IT WENT OVER